[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
if you've been around this channel for
the last few years you know that i fully
believe in free-to-play games and how
they offer experiences
to everyone which stand out in unique
ways
over the last few days i've been playing
genshin impact i'm sure you've heard of
it by now yeah
if you aren't playing this i think you
should let me explain
why this game is worth your time
[Music]
gentian impact is currently available on
ps4 pc
and mobile with a switch version coming
soon
and all of this game is absolutely free
with any free game
we should be aware of issues shall we
say which are designed to push players
towards buying things
we'll break down how gentian impact does
this soon and don't worry it's
remarkably well made
but for now let's concentrate on what
you get for zero pounds
zero dollars zero rupees zero euros
i can go on you get the idea it's free
[Music]
at its core gentian impact is a relaxed
exploration game
set on a new island your character is
free to venture anywhere you can
see but what genshin does fantastically
well is leave breadcrumbs of activities
literally everywhere around you your
desire to look around and wander
aimlessly
is rewarded constantly a set of ruins in
the distance could hide a puzzle to
solve
but on the way there a bandit camp may
take your eye and fighting to take their
treasure
becomes yet another side quest then an
npc may walk past
and ask for help all these activities
are naturally found without feeling
forced
i'm sure the nintendo gamers among you
have noticed the similarities to breath
of the wild
striking aren't they especially the
gliding used to travel vast distances
and the great ability to climb anything
you see
i mean anything it's great from all that
alone this game deserves a spot in your
collection
oh and by the way once i got to those
ruins i mentioned a world boss was
waiting to do battle
simply put if you like to explore
gentian impact
is the perfect game for you but what
about those who like a frantic battle
and those twitch reactions well that is
not a huge focus on genchin but there
are boss fights around the world each
with unique mechanics
so far in my 15 hours i've encountered
four unique boss fights
including a dragon a hulking beast with
a shield
a tetris cube and this thing an ugly
mocagent thing
each fight requires understanding of
tactics which can be simple enough to
spot
on this behemoth the trick was to keep
your distance and use
charged arrows to hit the weak points to
cause the beast to stagger
then switch character run in and smash
it into oblivion
when it arose again the cycle began
again keeping distance and using rock
faces to hide from projectiles
weakening the brute then running in to
take it down nothing too challenging but
this was a very early boss fight
these strats will need to be adapted for
other bosses like the tetris cube
i'm not going to show you that one it's
too good to spoil but i will show you
this one here's another boss you'll find
a lot in the world
his shield can be set ablaze therefore
nullifying his defense
pretty cool the combat itself is next on
the list and i'm sure you've noticed it
isn't the most deep
but there are indeed impressive things
of note our main character is joined by
others along the campaign
these can be switched in and out
instantly but each character has a
different approach to battle
some wield a small sword some are heavy
swords some are staff
and occasionally you'll find a hero with
a bow
the depth gen shin offers is chaining
their attacks to find weaknesses in
enemies by using elemental damage types
each character has a different core
element the first three you'll likely
encounter in the world
are pyro which is fire cryo which is ice
electro which is lightning and wind
which is referred to in game as
animo for all you uh anime fans each of
these attacks affect foes differently
and sometimes uniquely you can fight
fire with fire but the game implores you
to experiment with elemental damage
types
fun things happen with this for example
ice blasts will freeze water nearby
so it's also environmental impact and
the best thing for all you explorers
puzzles in the world can be elemental
specific meaning you'll need to pick the
perfect group
before beginning certain quests and i
think this is the perfect point to bring
in the way genshin wants your cash
first let me state you do not need to
spend any money to play this game
but unlike a game like fortnite where
the items are completely cosmetic
here the things you buy will impact your
gameplay massively
gentian impact wants players to buy
further characters to grow their team of
heroes
but here's the bit which is most
unpleasant from a buyer's perspective
the characters and weapons that are
purchased are not selectable
you do not know what you are buying
until it's already happened
yes that means this is a loot box game
if you've seen those vending machines
with children's toys inside
you'll know the feeling that that
invokes put in your money and turn the
lock to receive a mystery gift
sometimes that is what you expected
sometimes it's far beyond your wildest
dreams
and sometimes it's a depressing mess
games like this are referred to as gacha
games from the japanese word to
represent that vending machine
and right now i have to state as a
former teacher i've seen this affect
teenagers in my class
hard this is a dangerously addictive
thing
this is gambling which has very strict
laws but those laws become a little more
relaxed
in video game form so being aware of
this before you begin
is imperative as a quick point here i'm
happy to spend 100
in game to show you the highs and lows
of this catcher system
if you'd like to see that please leave a
comment and i'll do my best to waste my
money for you
just promise not to tell my girlfriend
who's currently listening behind me
so did i sell the addiction thing enough
i hope so
because i also think it's a great
mechanic too let me break it down
the new characters can be so gorgeous to
look at even for
non-weebs i mean noel's design is
appealing to me because of her bulking
great sword
this isn't a simple reskin either joelle
is a tank-like build whose sword takes
time to swing to hit the target
but is rewarded with heavier damage
numbers joelle also has an overshield
option
which protects her and remains in place
when switching to another character
therefore impacting your gameplay
massively oh and if you didn't know her
element is earth which in the game is
called
geo we haven't even touched on hydro and
dendro elements which are water and
nature too
i'm unable to check right now but this
got me thinking should a situation arise
where you need hydro power
yet you do not have a character that has
that ability what happens
this is a question i intend to find the
answer to but right now i haven't played
enough to really know this
i'm hoping the game will allow for
free-to-play players to get through this
somehow
but i'm not completely certain right now
i'm only 15 hours in
as this is speculation and not fact
let's leave that point there
just note that new characters change the
way you play the game
here's a cool thing to note the gacha
system has free goals so to speak
especially if you get the game during
the first few weeks
keep checking your in-game emails and
you will receive gift wishes
after chatting with other players the
recommendation is to pick up the
beginner's wish
pack which guarantees noel the character
we just talked about
and this also guarantees a four-star
item every 10 wishes
hmm i can feel that this is a slippery
slope towards spending money
if that's good with you go crazy it's
your cash if it isn't
remember to check yourself before you
wreck yourself
let's get away from loot boxes gentian
empac so far has been one of the
greatest rpgs i've ever played in the
free-to-play category
the animations are beautiful this
doesn't feel like a free game
the story isn't fantastic but it has
voice acting for about 80 percent of it
which makes things much more palatable i
was a nintendo kid growing up and i was
always frustrated that nobody
in game actually ever said anything
everything was text based
but now that's fixed by a company which
isn't nintendo
the breath of the wild elements work
very well in game and genjin builds on
these to make an experience
which just feels nice and i know that's
not the greatest way to explain a game
like this
it's not a great endorsement but it's
just chilled out
and enjoyable nice is a good word i had
hoped to tell you about another mechanic
which could be mind-blowing but i
haven't actually unlocked it yet
multiplayer
as we progress through the content our
adventurer rank grows
i'm currently at rank 13. if we get to
rank 16
the game opens up and adds an online
multiplayer mode
don't worry though it's not a must if
playing solo is your jam you stick to
that
but if you want to join three buddies
and take on a difficult dungeon together
or help a friend who's stuck on a boss
fight
or maybe just chill out and collect
things and loot together
the option is here and unlocks at
adventurer rank 16
which looks to be about 15 hours into
the game
i'm not there yet but by the time this
video releases i
should be i'll let you know about that
so there we have it genting impact the
mobile game
like no other mobile game that uses
gesture elements to grow your army of
heroes
all surrounded by one of the most
well-made open worlds filled with
puzzles looting
bosses and dungeons i think gentian
impact
has real possibility to be a huge game
for years and that's only from my first
15 hours with it
i recommend it give it a download i'd
love to know your thoughts
i'm adam from playstation grenade it's
been a pleasure
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you